[Música]
quem sabe o que é vencer
roupas a obter mais força para se
levantar a força interior que tem na
primeira não tem lei e fica penalizada
coragem pra você e seus sonhos desejos
amores anseio de lutas conquistas e
respeito quem você quer que ninguém quer
dizer sul e orientação perdido seu poder
converter seus sonhos reais e agora essa
é a chance não deixei de ir embora a
quina a moda osman no apito e leve que a
dança trapiche ea menina a dona osmano a
vítima em leve queda trânsito através de
[Música]
em cima e deixar a vida te levar seu
corpo suas regras têm que chamar deixar
a vida te levar meu português
sua orientação natureza sua decisão
duas empresas sua luta ativista sua vida
a conquista de direitos iguais para ser
diferente eu quero um mundo sem medo na
mente quem somos o que somos o que
desejamos que encontramos o plano da
mina money osman fim e f4 e pra fugir
as mina bola aos manuais mim e lésbica
tranqueira vestir
[Música]